[Música]
la actualidad más destacada del
continente africano está en Francia 24
Bienvenidos a África 7 días estos son
los titulares comenzamos esta edición
con el golpe de estado en burkina faso
donde el coronel da viva fue destituido
y sustituido por el capitán Ibrahim
traore este golpe el segundo en ocho
meses en el país ha ido además
acompañado por manifestaciones contra la
presencia francesa analizamos la
situación
senegal conmemora el aniversario número
20 del hundimiento del ferry chula que
terminó con la vida de casi 2.000
personas los familiares de las víctimas
aún esperan una respuesta de las
autoridades y en algunos casos esperan
recuperar los cuerpos de sus seres
queridos que permanecen en los restos
del naufragio
y al final de la edición les llevamos al
antiguo reino de daome en el actual
Benin la nueva superproducción
estadounidense the womanking se inspira
en la historia de su reina y recorre la
extraordinaria epopea de las amazonas
cuya historia les presentamos
comenzamos esta edición con el golpe de
estado en burkina faso país que estuvo
solo ocho meses bajo el mando del
Coronel pology damiba Y es que un nuevo
golpe de estado obligó finalmente a este
militar a entregar las llaves de la
presidencia que el mismo había tomado
por la fuerza su sucesor es el capitán
Ibrahim traore el nuevo presidente
autoproclamado reivindica las mismas
ambiciones que su predecesor en cuanto
al tema de la seguridad en un estado que
ha perdido el control de más del 40% de
su territorio a manos de los grupos y
aristas por otro lado las
manifestaciones de apoyo al nuevo golpe
fueron acompañadas de manifestaciones
contra Francia para analizar la
situación en burkina fazo nos acompaña
omer freixa historiador africanista
Señor freixa gracias por estar con
nosotros es importante entender la
espiral de inestabilidad en burkina faso
dos Golpes en un espacio relativamente
corto de tiempo Qué sucedió
pasado 30 de septiembre uno un capitán
un jefe de regimiento que es Ibrahim
traoré también les afecto esta vez
contra damiba contra la conducción de la
junta militar que había propuesto un
plazo peritorio de transición de tres
años ha dado un golpe dentro del golpe
algo que pasó malí entre 2020 y 2021 O
sea hay un efecto contagio tal vez en la
región Y
aduciendo una vez más además de
insuficiencia de gobernanza
gobernabilidad
cierta también cierta incapacidad de
combatir el proceso yihadista que está
cada vez más desbocado No solo en
burkina faso sino en la región completa
me parece también que ahí se ha
inclinado también la balanza un proceso
que está en la región que es cierto de
cierta
desafección con el mando francés hay que
recordar que a principios de año la gran
novedad fue que Francia se alejaba de
malí desarmó su operación barcan para
ese burkina faso también está muy
resentida muy cuestionada la presencia
francesa de hecho el sábado este sábado
apenas 48 horas se incendió la embajada
de Francia o gravísimo también se
atacaron
violadas en la segunda ciudad de la un
instituto francés O sea hay un hay una
desafección no solo con la fragancia
sino contra el propio gobierno y ahí hay
también es interesante porque hay una
decisión dentro del cuadro militar
dominante entre países sectores más
afectos a una postura francesa creo que
es también importante entender el rol de
los militares en burkina faso porque
asistimos a un golpe y a un contragolpe
por integrantes del mismo ejército Qué
papel juega el ejército en la estructura
del país hay divisiones o luchas por el
poder
el ejército está sobrepasado el país O
sea lo que es la estructura militar
apenas puede controlar con suerte el 60%
del territorio hecho las elecciones 2020
buena parte electoral no puedo votar
porque las zonas estaban bajo la
influenciadismo y era completamente
peligrosísimo o imposible generar las
elecciones acá como decía al principio
hay un ejército que está claramente
escindido en dos este dicho este mismo
grupo que decía al principio el
corresponde a la sigla de movimiento que
que nombre antes patriótico etcétera
está bastante
dividido y de hecho una de las quejas
fue que en estos meses que la los
militares no podían hacerse cargo de su
propio sostén y tenían que cazar porque
el estado no probía los medios básicos
de suministro militar y alimentación
etcétera los propios efectivos
urquinabed y con la presencia francesa
en cuestionamiento también va a ser más
difícil es sostener un esfuerzo por eso
ahí se habla como de una suerte de
relevo ruso Muchas gracias por haber
estado con milímetros
Gracias amable un abrazo hasta la
próxima
es considerado como uno de los mayores
naufragios de la historia reciente el 26
de septiembre de 2002 un ferry de la
ciudad de la región de casa mansa al sur
de senegal en dirección a la capital
Dakar el barco iba excesivamente
sobrecargado y acabó volcando en medio
del mar llevándose a casi todos los 2000
pasajeros que iban a bordo entre ellos
había familias menores de edad todo un
equipo de jóvenes futbolistas y
estudiantes que se preparaban para
empezar la universidad de las 2.000
personas a bordo sólo 64 sobrevivieron
estas son imágenes nunca vistas antes
del julan es ahora un barco de acero
totalmente oxidado
el ferry que se hundió con casi 2.000
personas a bordo muchas más que el
Titanic yace sobre la arena a 20 metros
de profundidad
sus hélices aún son visibles algunos
ojos de buey siguen abiertos más allá
algunos vehículos se encuentran volcados
pero también hay ropa clavada en vigas
pulseras joyas femeninas y muchos huesos
esta exploración excepcional que fue
realizada por un equipo Franco senegalés
ha marcado profundamente a este buzo
había personas que golpeaban contra el
casco del barco que seguían vivas los
servicios de rescate llegaron pero no
tenían medios técnicos para sacarlas Así
que las oyeron morir y me encontré en
esta parte donde hay muchos huesos se
han encontrado cientos de cuerpos que
han sido traídos a la playa por las
corrientes pero estamos lejos de haber
encontrado a todos
fue filmado unas horas antes de hundirse
El navío estaba abarrotado llevaba
cuatro veces más pasajeros de los
permitidos y cabeceaba peligrosamente
salió de casa manca y debía llegar a
Dakar durante la noche pero hacia las 23
horas local sorprendido por una tormenta
el transbordador volcó atrapando a sus
ocupantes
el barco empezó a inclinarse hacia la
izquierda
[Música]
el ejército ya no realizaba el
mantenimiento del ferry y la sobrecarga
era demasiado grande la justicia
senegalesa cerró el caso al cabo de un
año atribuyendo toda la responsabilidad
al Capitán que murió durante el
naufragio
actualmente en la ciudad se está
construyendo un monumento conmemorativo
que debería albergar los objetos
recuperados por el equipo Franco
senegalés la delicada cuestión de los
huesos presentes en el barco hundido
sigue sin respuesta 20 años después del
naufragio
como Lo acabamos de escuchar en el
informe la justicia senegal es hacerlo
el caso un año después del hundimiento
hoy 20 años después no se ha designado a
ninguna responsable ni se ha realizado
ningún juicio y los familiares de las
víctimas continúan haciendo reclamos a
las autoridades para conocer más
detalles contactamos a bubacarba
presidente de la asociación de
familiares de las víctimas
que perdió a sutillos su chía su hermano
mayor y a su sobrino de 8 años lleva
años luchando para que se haga justicia
y para que la tragedia no quede impune
o térmica creo sinceramente al cabo de
estos 20 años que ha habido un diálogo
de sordos entre nosotros como familias
de las víctimas y el estado senegalés la
producción la prueba es que el estado no
quiere reflotar el barco nosotros
creemos que es porque Quizás es un
elemento clave que será decisivo en
cuanto a la luz que queremos arrojar a
lo que
Cómo se trata de incriminar a altos
cargos militares en legaleses que
trabajaban en torno al barco pensamos
que quizás ciertamente quieren
protegerlos y por eso las autoridades no
quieren arrojar luz no se ha planteado
ninguna información judicial en este
caso
dos mil muertes sin que ningún juez se
decidan ni siquiera escuchar a los
Testigos Esto es lo que vivimos hoy han
pasado 20 años y queremos que se reabre
el caso la revertir YouTube
es posible lo único que hace falta es la
voluntad del jefe de estado de abrir
este expediente para que realmente
podamos saber lo que pasó en nuestra
sociología en algunas etnias te dicen
que cuando no encuentras el cuerpo no
puedes hacer el Duelo no se puede rezar
a nivel tradicional Así que hay todo un
conjunto de motivaciones que nos hacen
desear la recuperación de los restos
porque sin ello siempre estaremos
dudando sin realizar lo que realmente
pasó el 26 de septiembre de 2002
cambiamos ahora de tema para hablar de
cine La extraordinaria historia de Las
Minas Las amazonas del reino de daome en
África ha inspirado una película
estadounidense de Gran presupuesto
protagonizada por viola Davis the women
King esta película cuenta la historia de
una de las reinas de estas amazonas que
se distinguió en la defensa de su reino
ubicado en el actual benín contra los
colonizadores franceses en el siguiente
reportaje los llevamos precisamente al
antiguo Reino del jaume
en lo que hoy es Benin las ruinas de
dahjomi uno de los reinos más poderosos
de África occidental en el siglo XVIII
se extienden por casi 48 hectáreas las
amazonas de dajumi fueron derrotadas por
las tropas coloniales francesas pero sus
danzas y cantos de guerra han
permanecido intactos Durante los últimos
cuatro siglos
de valor al interpretar esta fuerte
coreografía y canción son como una
manada de hiena sedientas de sangre
al frente de esta tropa de élite llamada
ayojie en idioma local estaba la reina
cassiana la única mujer que reinó tras
tomar el poder por accidente después de
la muerte de su hermano gemelo el rey
acaba decidió disfrazarse de hombre creó
una Guardia exclusivamente femenina
porque es confiaba de los hombres que no
entendían su presencia en el poder
la propia reina iba a la guerra incluso
cuando estaba embarazada y después de
dar a luz los hombres la despreciaban
ella no se fiaba de ellos así que fue
este régimen de las mujeres lo que le
ayudó a reinar
aún así su reinado duró solo tres años
uno de sus hermanos la hizo a picar
matando a su hijo de la historia de las
primeras amazonas la actual
representante heredó este palo su
símbolo de poder quedan pocos objetos
que hayan pertenecido a las amazonas de
tajomi y la mayoría fueron sustraídos
por las tropas coloniales francesas
todos tenían un puñal así rajado en el
cinturón También tenían un arma blanca
llamada diente que se utilizaba para
degollar a los soldados enemigos
esta Fabulosa historia de Las amazonas
de superando a los hombres ha intentado
ser borrada ese día Gaby se alegró
denunciar a esta descendiente de las
amazonas el estreno una película en
occidente basada en su historia estoy
contento de que haya una película porque
eso promueve mi cultura mis orígenes las
mujeres se han sacrificado para defender
este país pero ya nadie habla de ello
hoy se ha hecho justicia sea cual sea el
contenido de la película Lo principal es
que hablemos de ellas
durante mucho tiempo la vida de la única
reina de benín fue ocultada en las
escuelas pero ahora los benimeses están
orgullosos de que la historia de la
primera de las amazonas y de su cuerpo
de mujer soldados se cuente en todo el
mundo
así termina la edición de esta semana
pero quédense con nosotros la actualidad
internacional continúa en Francia 24.com
[Música]